oh
I'm sorry hi I'm Ria today I'm going to
take a popular food and make it fancy I
usually Host this show by myself but
today I have a special guest judge me
hello
so Jasmine you join us as a taste tester
before but it's your first time to host
together yes I'm excited we're gonna
have a good time oh cool sure oh thanks
you can find it Link in description
let's see what we are making fancy today
I'm excited three two one oh
I think we have better kitkats in Asia I
feel like Asia comes up with really
really awesome KitKat flavors yeah this
is one of my favorite so this one it's
matcha Kika it says
it's adult sweetness oh adult sweetness
yeah what did you wink on me oh I didn't
wink you should like pause and Rewind oh
adult sweetness yeah there is a phrase
in Japanese says adult flavor oh an
adult flavor means not too sweet it's a
little bit like sophisticated oh yeah
and we're sophisticated because it's
make it fancy here
even though you open it it's fancy all
right let's have a break and have a
chica cheers
mmm So Sophisticated I think it's like
perfectly balanced out they did match a
Justice I already have a great idea so
are you ready you ready I am I don't
think so I have a surprise for you riere
this has gotten a little bit too easy
for you I got something specially made
for you shall we bring it in
ah why is this the wheel oh
dang what is real protein you spin this
we land on a protein and we have to
incorporate it into the dish all right
go for it
egg I think you wish it was egg but it's
fish
all right Let's Do It Jasmine I'm
excited to make it fancy I'm not too
excited to make it fussy all right so
here's what we got lemongrass green
onions snap beads and bok choy matcha
Ginger miso coconut milk shallots lime
garlic and mystery protein from the
pantry we got sesame oil soy sauce fish
sauce rice vinegar canola oil extra
virgin olive oil
and Miri all right let's get started
make it fancy First Step we're gonna do
a little surgery I want to separate
chocolate and wait for it so I'm gonna
just use paring knife okay and it's
great I usually separate it with my
teeth yeah well you can do it if you're
just eating by yourself but we're gonna
have a special guest so it's your
favorite person
oh it's really difficult what if we
tried oh let's try this all right oh
it's working it's much better wow oh
that works much better look how bare it
looks so if you ever have to separate
chocolate from Wafers this is a tool so
we're gonna keep doing this until we're
done with all our kitkats yes we're
making uh we'll see
we are going to separate all key Cuts in
this ball but before we moving on it's
the fancy time
[Music]
so we have ginger can you peel this yes
I like using spoon also you can use
backup knife I like using pack of knife
because I only need to wash one thing
that's true yeah so now we peel the
ginger I want to cut it very thin and
cut into matchsticks I want to make it
like super stain maybe I'll bring back
my uh your favorite tool my peeler yes
and I'll do the same yeah another tasty
hack oh nice nice and safe what are we
making I think I love things right so
now we have a nice plain sliced Ginger
and just stuck them up and make much tea
and now we are going to deep fry oh okay
so we have KitKat Wafers can you crush
four four yes okay we're gonna use the
rest later like a very fine powder like
breadcrumbs and I'm going to fry Ginger
good and why do you talk can you put
this into the KitKat dust kind of call
it lady how interesting I bet this will
be so yummy
mmm fun fact did you know KitKat has
released 200 special flavors since the
year 2000. can you name all yeah so
there's matcha creme brulee there's sake
wow you've named the 200 of them that's
right I did so this is done we are ready
for next we have chopped rest of the
ginger and I have meeting sesame oil soy
sauce vinegar and miso and we're gonna
put in a pot you kind of want to put
medium first because it has alcohol in
it and you want to put miso last because
the Miso has enzyme it's a fermented
product I'm going to reduce it a little
bit thickens okay I think the Grays is
ready so can you crush the way first all
right and I'm gonna mix it so I'm gonna
add this since it's a little chunky
let's use blender to emulsify it looks
good let's taste it cheers cheers
it's very strong at this point but I
think it's gonna complement what we are
going to make it today and we are making
um
yeah let's go to next step I thought it
was gonna work we have all the aromatics
and I want to saute them we have canola
oil you wanna add shallots we got some
garlic lemongrass lemongrass Ginger we
want to saute until very soft and all
the aromatics we chose today is very
strong flavor so we kind of want to mask
some of the sweetness I'm liking this so
far because we're making um
yeah right I I don't remember you know
like she won't fudge sprinkle salt and
it helps cook faster too it's draw
moisture from the ingredients we are
going to add coconut milk and fish sauce
and I think you like spicy I love spicy
So Thai Chili it's very spicy like how
spicy do you want to go both maybe we're
gonna keep the seed yeah okay wow all
right so it's gonna be nice cake you
don't want to boil coconut milk because
fat separate so we're gonna wait until
it Simmons but I have Kika fact Kika
it's constant like lucky snack because
Kika in Japanese way of saying is
kitokatsu kitokatsu means so whenever
you have to take exam of Kika right so
it's simmering and let's add matcha
chocolate from KitKat it's nice
yeah nice and green let's taste it my
favorite part I think we need a little
salt yeah but it's good yeah like
overall the flavor very very balanced
but I think I need a little bit salt I
like to say that sodium is my favorite
food group oh I like that it's time for
the mystery protein oh my gosh I'm so
excited it didn't specify what kind of
fish so I got Hollywood I love Halloween
we're gonna poach this fish and this
Cooks super quick okay let's put the lid
back and cook until the fish is fully
cooked
nice the fish is fully poached so I'm
going to remove fish and we're gonna
strain this so flaky and it's broken
you know it does still tastes the same
and we want to strain because we don't
need aromatics anymore so the color I
feel like earlier was a little bit more
Bible on but it kind of now sour cream
so I want to make it more vibrant so
let's put butter to boost the color
we're gonna use matcha we already use
matcha Kika so I think it's a nice
complement flavor so let's sift now we
are using culinary matcha culinary
matcha is less expensive so perfect for
using for cooking or baking so let's add
coconut milk and whisk it this is so
beautifully green yay come away
from sad green to Glad green yeah so we
have some vegetables in bok choy and
snap beads we don't need to cook too
much you can eat those like raw and you
kind of want to have some crunch so we
kind of cook it left over here I also
love adding greens so it also kind of
Pops the color and we're gonna just cook
like this use their you know Steam and
we are going to grate The Fishery
poached earlier how much do you want me
to put on there go generous I'm a sauce
girl so let's go yeah I love sauce so
we're gonna touch the fish and it's not
for cooking purpose you just want to
have like charred color now we're gonna
plate rice it's a Shrek or a comet I
think Shrek because Shrek is love Shrek
is life I actually never watch Shrek
I can finally see what this dish has
become last but not least I'm gonna
squeeze lime juice
[Music]
curry with poach the haribert Shrek
fancy very very sexy let's bring our
mutual friend do you know who is our
friend who feeds Shrek Shrek I'm a guest
special guest is very tall maybe green
oh okay coming our special guest hello
did I hear very tall maybe green
I had to make a fancy now
yeah we are so excited to have you we
made some special dish do you want to
open I would love to do anything under a
clothes you can't see right yeah here we
go
oh
my gosh do you eat anything I eat
everything I hate to go like heat
tolerance pretty high I'm a sweater
though I am definitely a sweater so it
looks like I'm dying but I'm actually
really chilling cool about it we made a
green curry but we made with special
ingredients and we like YouTube guests
oh I'd be honored okay weed again it's a
popular snack ah
you did ask about spice so far I'm okay
there's definitely a fish first of all
delish oh thank you I'm obsessed it's a
sweet snack
my taste buds are not sophisticated more
like a candy even it's definitely not a
chocolate because that would be
clinically ill that would be insane I
think it's more of a gummy
of course yes I'm thinking like a
Toblerone that feels fancy like a
Snickers
am I getting their clothes
is it a freaking KitKat yeah okay No
One's Gonna believe me but I swear I was
thinking KitKat and then some forces
some external forces told me to say
Snicker you know how there's like a
green matcha KitKat could that be the
sitch oh is that the sitch yeah
cheers
did we make matcha Kika fancy absolutely
[Music]
so we have one last thing to do three
two one make it fancy so Tucker I know
you said you were good with heat I did
whoa I like to test that today wait are
we all or just yeah I'll partake I will
do it too
[Music]
there's still kind of so far I'm gonna
probably start sweating thank you so
much sometimes I get the hiccups I feel
like when I eat something spicy
okay isn't that bad oh am I eyes
ordering it's like barely even here
foreign
[Music]